the surgeon will perform
bariatric surgery if the effort to lose
weight through lifestyle changes
and medications has not been successful
there are two types of
bariatric surgery restrictive procedures
decrease the size of the stomach so
that the person feels full
quickly after surgery  the
stomach tolerates one cup of food a
normal stomach tolerates between 4 and 6
cups malabsorptive procedures
decrease the absorption of calories in
the small intestine
before surgery an intravenous line will be placed
bariatric surgery
requires general anesthesia which will
keep you asleep during the procedure
procedure
a breathing tube will be inserted through the
mouth and into the trachea to help you
breathe during the operation
gastric bypass technically known
as gastric bypass
is a restrictive and poorly
absorptive procedure as it reduces the size of the
stomach and decreases the absorption of
calories in the  small intestine
the  surgeon will use one of two
methods of gastric bypass surgery the
open method requires an
8 to 10 inch 20 to 25
centimeter incision in the abdomen the
laparoscopic method only requires several
small, key incisions through
which the surgeon will pass a
copy  and surgical instruments a
laparoscope is a thin lighted instrument
that projects images of the
surgery on a monitor in the operating room
during ruben gastric bypass surgery
and the surgeon will use
surgical staples to create a small
compartment that will function as a
new stomach this bag will tolerate  a
cup of food the lower part of the
stomach continues to secrete
digestive juices but receives no food
then the surgeon will cut the
small intestine well away from the stomach
lift one of the free ends
and attach it to the pouch then attach
the lower free end to
the small intestine  forming one
by bypassing the pa  lower
stomach and first part of
the small intestine fewer calories will be absorbed
as food travels this
new path banding techniques are
restrictive procedures they help
decrease food intake in two
ways by shrinking the stomach to the size
of a small pouch and creating  a
tiny opening from the pouch to the
rest of the
stomach food passes slowly
through this opening these factors will make
you feel full faster and
for a longer time in
vertical banded gastroplasty
also known as bbg or stomach stapling
the surgeon will open a  window at the
top of the stomach will
staple the stomach around the
window and into the esophagus to create
a small pocket at the top
then the surgeon will pass a
rigid plastic band through the window
will fold around the small
hole  out of the bag which
will prevent stretching  food will pass
from this pouch through a
tiny opening into the
lower stomach and the rest of the digestive tract
during an adjustable gastric band surgery
also known as hb or la
band the surgeon will place an
inflatable band around the top
of the  stomach as the band is inflatable it will
squeeze the stomach to create a
small pouch and a narrow opening
to the wider bottom
can be made through
tiny incisions using a laparoscope the
band can be adjusted at any
time
the biliopancreatic diversion is a
malabsorptive procedure that
decreases  the amount of calories
absorbed in the small intestine
the surgeon will start by removing part
of the stomach and leaving only a small
pouch behind then sewing the
small intestine to the pouch
this creates a direct path from the
pouch to the end of the small intestine the
duodenum and the  jejunum are
bypassed consequently  absorb few
calories and nutrients
for all methods of bariatric surgery
the surgeon will close the incisions with
staples or stitches after surgery
your breathing tube will be removed and you will be
taken to the recovery area for
monitoring you will be given
medications for pain and  diet
will progress gradually over several
days